una arraigada a la creencia sobre
presuntas irregularidades en los votos
la campaña de down sounds señaló que la
batalla continúa esta elección no ha
terminado estamos lejos de eso apenas
hemos iniciado el proceso de obtener un
conteo acertado y honesto estamos
luchando por los derechos de todos los
estadounidenses que quieran tener fe y
confianza no sólo en esta elección sino
también en las venideras
brendan venía watkins la campaña está
tomando acción legal en varios estados y
este lunes presentó una demanda en
pensilvania buscando una orden para
bloquear a este estado y no permitirle
certificar los resultados de las
elecciones justo después se conoció que
el fiscal general william bar le dijo a
los fiscales federales que revisaran los
alegatos de la campaña de trump que
masifica el presunto fraude electoral
en un memorando enviado a los fiscales
william bar los autorizó a investigar
los alegatos sustanciales de votos e
irregularidades en sus tabulaciones y
además que ignoraran los reclamos
especulativos fantasiosos y
descabellados la instrucción fue dada a
pesar de la falta de evidencia de fraude
presentada por bart un aliado de champ
su intervención se da justo cuando el
presidente se rehúsa concede su derrota
a un activo en twitter yendo a sus
clases de golf
trump no ha sido visto en público en la
última semana algunos expertos dicen que
los retos legales de su campaña son
mínimos e incapaces de cambiar los
resultados de las elecciones